albert einstein was so smart that
scientists studied his brain after he
died to figure out why
he was such an icon that time magazine
named him person of the century in 1999
but despite his fame the world's
best-known scientist had his secrets
the fbi kept a clandestine file on him
and he had an illegitimate child
to name just two this is the story of
albert einstein
in full einstein was born in om in
southwestern germany on march 14
1879. the family moved to munich just a
few weeks later where he grew up with
his younger sister
when he was five years old he felt ill
one day and his father gave him a
compass to cheer him up
einstein was amazed that the needle
always pointed to the magnetic north no
matter which way he turned the compass
in his autobiographical notes he
recalled i can still remember or at
least believe i can remember
that this experience made a deep and
lasting impression upon me
something deeply hidden had to be behind
things so began a lifelong fascination
with physics
he later said if he hadn't become a
physicist he'd probably be a musician
he loved music especially mozart's
sonatas
unlike many geniuses einstein wasn't a
child prodigy
he didn't speak full sentences until he
was five according to his biographers
his parents were understandably worried
but when he got into school
einstein came into his own his family
was jewish but he attended a catholic
elementary school where he excelled as a
student
there was a rumor going around that he
flunked math but to the contrary
einstein said that he had already
mastered differential and integral
calculus before the age of 15.
for a while his father hermann ran a
small electrochemical plant
but he struggled to keep it going
eventually he moved his family to italy
in the hopes of finding new
opportunities
young albert stayed behind to finish
high school but he hated school where
success depended on memorization and
obeying authority
he was a rebel and apparently through
temper tantrums one exasperated teacher
even said he would never amount to
anything
einstein dropped out at age 15. he also
renounced his german citizenship which
got him out of mandatory military
service
for a few years he belonged to no
country and loathed nationalism
preferring to be a citizen of the world
when he did eventually become a citizen
again it was swiss
when he moved to switzerland he tried to
get admitted to the prestigious swiss
federal institute of technology
he did well in the math and physics
section of the entrance exam
but is said to have done horribly in
language zoology and botany
it didn't help that the exam was in
french so he didn't get in and instead
continued his high school studies
he was a good student scoring the
highest possible grade of six in many
subjects
including math and physics with this
under his belt he was automatically
admitted to the swiss federal institute
of technology
where he had originally flunked the
entrance exam he enrolled in a four-year
teaching program in math and physics
that's where he met his future wife
maleva marich the only female student in
his physics class
einstein's private letters discovered in
the 80s caused a sensation
because they revealed the couple had a
child out of wedlock a daughter named
lizel according to their correspondence
liza was born in 1902
a year before her parents married she
was cared for by her mother while
staying with her family in her native
serbia while einstein worked in
switzerland
march would later join einstein without
the child
it's unclear what happened to their
daughter historians believe she
either died in infancy probably from
scarlet fever or was given up for
adoption
maurice and einstein would have two sons
after they married
the eldest hans albert said einstein
wasn't a good father
remarking probably the only project he
ever gave up on
was me in 1901 einstein received his
diploma to teach physics and math
but he struggled to find an academic
position after two years of searching
he's said to have even applied to teach
high school eventually he worked at the
swiss patent office in bern for seven
years
this job would be a blessing in disguise
it wasn't mentally challenging
and he found that when he was done
evaluating patents for the day he could
use the rest of his time to work on
scientific research
his real passion 1905 was einstein's
year of miracles he wrote four papers in
a german scientific journal
that changed the way we see the universe
i'll try to explain them as simply as
possible
einstein is believed to have said if you
can't explain it simply you don't
understand it well enough
the first was his theory of light a
physicist at the time believed light was
a wave
but it didn't make sense that light
could create an electric current
einstein proposed that light was
actually made up of a stream of
particles called
photons and these photons can knock an
electron off an atom to create a current
this is the photoelectric effect his
second paper made a case for the
existence of atoms
he observed what seemed like the random
movement of particles in water
and reason that it's not so random if
the water is actually made up of
invisible atoms that cause the particles
to jiggle
this was called brownian motion after
the botanist robert brown who had
observed the phenomenon earlier
his third and most famous discovery is a
special theory of relativity
in which it's impossible to say if two
events occurred at the same time
if those events are separated in space a
b and c
all happen at the same time however they
appear to occur in a different order
depending on the location of the
observer
or let's say someone in london starts
running at the same time as someone in
new york
they would appear to start running at
different times if the observer is on a
plane flying between london
and new york relativity is the basis of
the world's most famous
formula e equals m c squared his fourth
paper gave us this equation which shows
how energy equals mass
times the speed of light squared in case
you're feeling somewhat intellectually
challenged at this point
einstein once said do not worry about
your difficulties in mathematics
i can assure you mine are still greater
so under the right conditions
energy can become mass and mass can
become energy
here's an example take a paperclip to
find out how much energy is inside of it
you'd multiply
its mass by the speed of light squared
if you could turn every one of the atoms
in this paper clip into pure energy
leaving no mass then this paperclip will
be as powerful as the bomb that
destroyed hiroshima
indeed physicists began to consider
whether his equation might actually make
an atomic bomb
possible as einstein gained greater
prestige his wife gained more household
work
marge was also passionate about math and
science but gave up her own ambitions to
care for their children
there is even some evidence she helped
her husband develop some of the concepts
in his famous papers
in einstein's letters to her he
referenced bringing our work on relative
motion
to a successful conclusion the papers
would transform him from an unknown
patent office clerk to a renowned
genius he would go on to teach physics
at universities in prague
zurich and berlin where he reacquired
german citizenship
and spent his time during world war one
war by the way
disgusted him although his professional
life was going well
his personal life suffered einstein
would write to his first love
mary wintler whom he met as a teenager
he spilled his heart out to her saying
how much he missed her and how he
thought of her whenever he had a free
moment
it was perhaps no surprise when he and
his wife eventually split up
maurice took the boys to zurich while
einstein remained in berlin
they divorced in 1919 and immediately
after einstein married his first cousin
elsa lowenthal with whom he had been
having an affair for years
he would later end up cheating on elsa
as well as part of the divorce agreement
with marriage
she would receive money from a nobel
prize if he were to ever win one
and he did in 1921 for his theory of
light not his theory of relativity
there was something about his relativity
theory that kept nagging at him
because it didn't acknowledge the
existence of gravity so he tinkered with
it for 10 years before coming up with
his
general theory of relativity which
completed the picture
200 years before einstein sir isaac
newton provided the world with insight
into gravity but didn't explain how it
worked
how is it that the sun pulls on the
earth einstein's general theory of
relativity
says something heavy like the sun causes
a warp or a dent
in space the earth is impacted by the
dent and rolls around the sun like a
marble rolling in a bowl
in other words orbits his theory also
suggested that light from another star
would be bent by the sun's gravity
if this were true then starlight passing
by the sun would be bent
so that we on earth would think that the
apparent location of the star
is different than it really is this
theory was considered to be preposterous
at the time and could only be proven
during a total solar eclipse when the
moon blocks out the bright light of the
sun
and that's exactly what happened in 1919
english astronomer sir arthur eddington
traveled to the coast of west africa to
photograph the total solar eclipse
the sun had in fact deflected the light
recently einstein was proved right once
again
stanford university astrophysicists saw
light behind a black hole for the first
time
which is strange because black holes
have such a strong gravitational pull
that light cannot escape them the reason
we can see light
is that the black hole is warping space
and bending light as predicted by
general relativity
einstein became a celebrity overnight
instantly recognizable thanks to immense
press coverage
even though his theory meant very little
to the average person the world needed
something to celebrate
after a long and horrifying war he began
traveling abroad going to asia the
middle east and the u.s where he gave
lectures at columbia university in
princeton
he published an essay on his first
impression of america in 1921
noting what strikes a visitor is the
joyous positive attitude to life
the american is friendly self-confident
optimistic
and without envy he would make more
trips to the u.s and while on one of
these visits in early 1933
he came to the stark realization that he
could never return to germany
the nazis had come to power under adolf
hitler and einstein was everything the
dictator hated
he was jewish he was part of the
intelligentsia and he was a pacifist a
german magazine listed him as an enemy
of the regime with a caption
not yet hanged and reportedly put a 5
000 price tag on his head
when he returned to europe he went to
belgium where he renounced his german
citizenship he then traveled to england
einstein had offers to teach at oxford
and several european universities
but chose to emigrate to the us he took
up a faculty position
at the institute for advanced study in
princeton new jersey where he remained
for the rest of his life
many prestigious american universities
like harvard and yale had very few
jewish faculty or students as a result
of discriminatory quotas
by the time he had arrived in the u.s
his best scientific research was already
behind him
nothing would trump his theory of
relativity or his other work
he tried and failed to find one equation
to explain all of the forces of nature
despite the stability he found at the
research institution life
wasn't always easy for einstein his
younger son edward was diagnosed with
schizophrenia and suffered
his first mental breakdown his wife elsa
suffered from a painful illness that
would take her life in 1936.
and to his horror scientists began to
look at whether his equation e
equals m c squared could in fact make an
atomic bomb
einstein detested war he had dedicated
much of his time to writing about peace
however despite being a pacifist he was
alarmed by the rise of fascism
and signed a letter to president
roosevelt in 1939
warning him that the nazis were working
on an atomic bomb
this led roosevelt to set up the
manhattan project the secret
american-led effort to develop an atomic
weapon
einstein's formula was key to its
success but he wasn't involved with the
project himself
because the fbi didn't trust him
washington considered him a security
risk because of his association with the
peace movement and socialist
organizations
the fbi kept tabs on him they had a
dossier that grew to over 1400 files
fbi director j edgar hoover even
recommended he be kept out of america
under the alien exclusion act though
this was overruled by the state
department
einstein was also a civil rights
activist as a jewish scientist who
experienced anti-semitism in germany
he was taken aback by racial segregation
in the u.s
in 1946 he traveled to lincoln
university
a small university in pennsylvania that
was the first to grant degrees to blacks
he gave a speech in which he called
racism a disease of white people
i do not intend to be quiet about it yet
it appears he was not immune to the
disease
his private diaries would reveal
prejudiced attitudes toward other races
in the 1920s he traveled throughout asia
and wrote that the chinese were an
industrious
filthy obtuse people it would be a pity
if these chinese supplant all other
races
for the likes of us the mere thought is
unspeakably dreary
these words are in stark contrast with
his public image
in 1940 einstein became a citizen of the
united states
his commitment to the cause of peace led
him to champion the creation of a
one-world
government he initially rejected the
idea of a jewish state on the grounds of
detesting nationalism
however after seeing the persecution of
jews in europe he promoted the zionist
cause of a jewish nation
even though he was personally torn over
the issue einstein would say my
relationship to the jewish people has
become my strongest human bond
though he wasn't religious he didn't
believe in a personal god and preferred
to be called an agnostic
the state of israel was created in 1948
and in 1952 israel's prime minister
david ben-gurion offered einstein the
post of president
einstein declined explaining that he had
spent his life dealing with objective
matters and lacked the aptitude and
experience of dealing with people
he was smart enough to know his own
shortcomings
on april 17 1955 einstein checked
himself into princeton hospital in new
jersey after his abdominal aortic
aneurysm burst
the aorta is the largest blood vessel in
the body he had previously had surgery
on it
this time he refused surgery saying it
was tasteless to prolong life and that
it was time
to go he died the next day mumbling a
few words in german before taking his
last breath
the nurse on duty didn't understand
german and couldn't repeat it so what he
said is lost in history
einstein's remains were cremated in his
ashes scattered in a secret spot along
the delaware river
those ashes didn't include his brain a
pathologist named thomas harvey removed
his brain so that scientists could try
to figure out why he was so intelligent
but he did so without permission after
einstein's family found out he
eventually got the okay to use the brain
for scientific research
einstein's brain was found to be missing
a bordering region called the lateral
sulcus
which researchers believe may have led
neurons in this part of the brain to
communicate
better scientists also believe his
neurons used up more energy
because his brain was found to have a
higher percentage of glial cells which
nourish
support and protect the neurons the
pathologist then cut up the brain into
pieces stored it into jars preserved in
formaldehyde
and kept it in his basement today the
most celebrated brain in the world
is in pieces at the motor museum in
philadelphia
it's hard to imagine what einstein would
think of all this attention he
specifically wanted to be cremated so
that people wouldn't worship his body
but worshiped he is the 99th element of
the periodic table is named after him
einsteinium was discovered shortly after
his death
albert einstein lives on as one of the
smartest people in history
who changed the way we view and
understand the world and the universe
he was influential in supporting so many
other causes besides science
he lived an extraordinary life
wouldn't it be incredible if all of
einstein's lectures were available
online right now there is a new way of
learning thanks to my sponsor
skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community where you get access
to thousands of classes on a variety of
topics
there are classes on everything from
learning how to create engaging youtube
videos with mkbhd
the first 10 seconds i would say is the
most
important 10 seconds of your video to
editing those videos to taking better
photos with your dslr
and with my special link in the
description it's free to try out for a
month
each class is broken up into short
sections and there are no tests and
again skillshare is completely free to
try out if you use the link in my
description
thanks so much for watching if you like
what you saw give it a like and don't
forget to subscribe to my channel
for newsthink i'm cindy palm